we are one day away I mean I can't
believe after all these months of
talking about it and years of supposing
it might happen it's finally gonna
happen in Las Vegas Nevada tomorrow
night a touching of 8 ounce gloves
between McGregor and Mayweather and the
president of the UFC who helped make
this all happen Dana White here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Dana I'm
good good morning good seem to you so
how how would you describe yourself
right now what's the emotion what do you
got nervous I haven't been nervous like
this in a long time you know normally
we'll put on an event that's my guy vs.
my guy this now it's my guy versus their
guy so what would you say is at stake in
this fight well you know for the if
Conor McGregor beats Floyd Mayweather
Conor McGregor will go down as the
greatest combat athlete of all time and
obviously for Floyd this is all about
getting that 50 and becoming 15 you know
and for the sport for UFC as a whole I
mean is that part of what makes you
nervous here is how McGregor McGregor
does in the ring in that square ring
tomorrow night um I'm more nervous about
the fight you know and and you know when
you talk to Connor McGregor it sit in a
room with this guy for five minutes man
he is so confident and absolutely
positive that he is gonna knock Boyd
Mayweather out and he's gonna knock him
out early so it's just Conor McGregor is
a fascinating human being you know
unlike any other fighter I've ever dealt
with I call him the Unicorn and it's
just I'm excited for this thing to
happen when did you first meet him once
that first time you slayed I was I was
actually in Ireland I received an award
from Trinity College and all the fans
out there kept telling me Conor McGregor
Conor McGregor Conor McGregor so I came
back and I asked my matchmakers who is
this Conor McGregor guy so they showed
me who he was I flew him out had dinner
with him and by the time I was done with
dinner I called my partner at the time
Lorenzo 14 and said let me tell you what
buddy I don't know if this guy can fight
but if he can even throw a punch he's
gonna be a massive star yeah I mean it
seems like he said he's straight out of
like a die ricci movie Dana that's what
I can say you know like lock
Stock Two Smoking Barrels with with
Conor McGregor for real it's so true
no he really is he is he's a very very
unique individual and an amazing fighter
the other thing that's exciting about
this fight is I stopped doubting the kid
a long time ago and everything that he
has said he would do in the UFC he has
done so now I'm just just excited to see
the next chapter UFC president Dana
White joining us the day before
Mayweather and McGregor fight in in Las
Vegas Nevada
we had al Bernstein who's gonna be
calling the match on Showtime saying
that he thinks McGregor has to be very
physical and straddle the line of being
dirty to win
do you agree yeah he needs to absolutely
be physical he needs to rough Lloyd up
you know he's a southpaw you know which
Floyd if you want to say there's any
type of kink in the armor than South
positive Bennett and let's not forget
would mayweather is gonna be 41 years
old this year
McGregor just turned 29 he is the bigger
stronger man he's the younger guy and he
hits like a truck and they got a Dallas
gloves on yeah I know you were you and
McGregor were very pleased about that
decision what's in the contract to make
sure that um that McGregor doesn't do
anything octagon --is-- in this square
ring Dana yeah there's a couple of
things there are provisions in the
contract that'll be very very bad if he
did that the other thing is if you look
at Floyd Mayweather's last three fights
including this one and how much leave
the kid has made you know the civil
lawsuit would would destroy Conor
McGregor what do you mean you would
destroy him meaning he could take
everything that Connor has well when you
go into a lawsuit it's all about what
are the damages and obviously the the
financial damages of him doing something
you know outside of the rules would be
massive in a lawsuit for Connor Plus
yeah I thought a commission would would
take the check I mean it's just
financially it would be devastating well
I know I know you're a busy man so I
want to hit some other items with you
before you go about your business the
day before here
what is the scoop with John Jones his
title are you gonna strip him of it well
he has to go through the process right
now with you sada in the California
State Athletic Commission so gonna get
this weekend behind me and then and then
focus on that but he he really right now
is waiting for you sada in California to
get together and figure this thing out
so if you had a heart of hearts do you
think you ever see Jon Jones fight in
the UFC again
Dana I think it's gonna be a few years
hmm what about Ronda Rousey when was the
last time you spoke to her Ronda Rousey
gets married tomorrow
yeah tomorrow's our wedding and you know
she's in a good place she's really happy
and she hasn't
enesta retirement or anything like that
but she's focusing on this wedding so
tell me she's honeymooning in Vegas next
to you by tomorrow night Dana please get
married of all the days you know she's
like I'm getting married congratulations
when you come to the wedding I said
absolutely the wedding's tomorrow okay
maybe she could just elope to Vegas and
you know kill all birds with one stone
better phrase and and is it true that
you were asked last minute to find
somebody to sing the Irish national
anthem tomorrow night on behalf of Conor
McGregor is that true Dan it's true we
you know we're not handling the
production on this thing so we get a
call on Tuesday basically saying okay we
got Demi Lovato for the American side
who are you getting for the Irish so
we're like what how is this even
possible how does this work and yeah so
we started to scramble on Tuesday to
figure out who we could get you know and
off the top of your head I mean I do you
think about people who can sing the
Irish national anthem obviously Bono is
the first thing that pops into your head
and then you know probably the
cranberries and you know I'm not up on
all my here Irish rock yeah so you
picked up the phone and call Bono yeah
so we call we actually call Jimmy Iovine
of course called Jimmy Iovine and Jimmy
Iovine got bono on the phone bono
out
solutely wanted to do it but he had a
wedding maybe he's going around it could
be officiating Danny you never know
would bond oh yeah so you call a guy
like Bono on three days notice for
something like this is is insane but hey
you got to take a shot right yeah I know
and but but Jimmy Iovine must have
another Irish superstar in his back
pocket right Dana yeah Jimmy I've got
quite a rolodex all right so last one
for you who tell me about the Dana White
entourage for tomorrow night how are you
taking in this fighting with who yeah so
uh you know I'm obviously you know I got
some things to do there but I'm just a
fan tomorrow so I I'm going with my
family and we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna see when's my old partner Lorenzo
vaquita and Frank Fertitta are coming so
I'm gonna sit with them hang out and
have fun what about the Patriots I know
you're tell--you're in New England
Patriot Guard II who else you got crap
Kraft is coming yep okay I'm just coming
and you know I can talk about the next
Super Bowl ring yeah I'm excited
okay Dana let's let's chat when your
plate isn't so full I'd love to have you
in studio as well here in Los Angeles I
would love that too okay down salute
pleasure have a great weekend right back
at home aggregor
okay that's Dana White at Dana White on
Twitter Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country
and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy